do you Jeff some shows that you think if
you re watch it you won't enjoy as much
oh you know what the same heads 90% I
think yeah yeah because I feel like
that's why I caught and I can never get
behind watching anime weekly cuz me can
I can't I I can't because it's because
like I'm always in a different headspace
some show there's some shows that like
transcend that and like you're there so
hype such as attack on Titan watching
that Weekly was like - [ __ ] every single
week no matter what that one day it came
out I was hyped to [ __ ] for that [ __ ]
cuz I binge that whole see right yeah
like it was such a good episode by
episode that like even though it sucked
it sucked have to wait a week it was so
good cuz that one day in the week you
got like a tree and didn't matter how
bad your mood was away your headspace is
that for 25 minutes you just shut your
brain off and just have a [ __ ] time
it was great man I used to be able to do
that so easily when I was in high school
and uni but and is well joining inin
like this the discourse online you know
like talking about I feel I feel like
that's a different side that I never got
growing up with anime which is the
social aspects because for me it was
just I watch a show and I'm like that
was an amazing show and happy I want to
talk has quickly become one of my
favorite parts of like watching anime
and it's why I like I caught up to Demon
Slayer on episode 19 yeah like if I
wanted to get involved with the the
social discourse good the great like
it's it's made of so if a show has like
a bad ending or something I still enjoy
it because like I remember when darling
the Franks ended and there was this
shift at like episode 18 or 20 I got him
the exact episode and then everyone lost
their [ __ ] and like it's not a good
ending but I had a blast watching it you
know I just realized something
I remember that you know when Big Ed was
a thing I know bear with me the shit's
gonna make sense but you get from 90 day
fiancé
like it was you know great memes
fantastic I want to start watching named
a fiance because of that yeah I was like
it's just like not the same I was
watching it I was like ah it's cuz I
need the YouTube comments for everything
cuz it's like one thing to have a clip
is it's funny but what is like
the perfect YouTube thread station is so
fine oh yeah like and also when
someone's an [ __ ] not even show you
want to be like everyone else thinks
this guy's an [ __ ] right let me go
check the comments yeah because do you
get this now where you watch some
YouTube videos or clip some shows or
YouTube video where they do something in
the clip and that's the moment where you
open up the comments yeah I hope
everyone's talking about this and that's
what I love about watching anime weekly
is that you get that kind of like
everyone's gonna be talking about that
thing that just happened on yeah
probably fun I love trying again on that
but they're like like you ever get
personally offended when you go in a
YouTube video and then the comments are
disabled like like something you never
wanted to comment on or you never yeah
if it's just most of it is like anime
trailers or anime opening sometimes I
see the comments that they say but I'm
like I don't know why but I feel
offended
are you [ __ ] yeah I tell like
American for like five seconds online
free speech
where's my second America